hey what's up guys Marquez from the
mkbhd channel here with an amazing pair
of headphones for under 100 bucks in
fact for 99 bucks these are the grotto
SR 80 is and there are an open back pair
of headphones they are really really
good for beginning audio files or people
just starting to get into audio and
music and headphones and if this video
gets 800 likes I've done this before
with headphones be giving away a pair on
Twitter so you can follow mkbhd the link
is in the description so you can get in
on that without any further ado let's go
ahead and take a look at the SR 80 eyes
so straight out the box you can see
these headphones have a sort of a dare I
say it vintage kind of look some people
may really like this others just like a
more modern look but these definitely
have a unique style to them but we'll
start from the bottom and work our way
up these guys have a three-and-a-half
millimeter gold-plated headphone jack
that's pretty durable and they come with
the quarter inch adapter too and the
court itself while it is really thick is
also really really durable so a good job
from Grotto these will practically never
tangle ever and something else unique
about these headphones is the cord it
splits through this wide joint and
connects to both ears of the headphones
so love it or hate it you know I'm not
really sure why they decided to do this
but it's not a deal-breaker at all now
on to the headphones and you can see the
open back design which I'll get into in
a second but also note the design of
these flat foam pads that happen to be
removable and of course that also means
replaceable if you ever get tired of
them or happen to damage them somehow
and you might even be able to get
different sound out of different pads
now these guys are pretty adjustable too
but note they don't exactly have notches
which may bother you if you have OCD but
they're they're also pretty comfortable
to the leatherette sort of headphone
band up here at the top isn't actually
padded at all but that doesn't bother me
because it's just sitting on top of my
head and you can see where they saved
money on some parts of the headphones
and put that money saved into the sound
quality but the comfort level comes from
being able to listen to these headphones
no matter how absurd your head shape or
sizes yeah see there you got one of the
cups rotate 360 degrees each and it's
pretty flexible and it's not going to
snap if it was made of plastic it
probably would but don't actually twist
these too much because remember the
cables are connected at the bottom so
you get like a twisted wire II knot of
wires so just avoid twisting it too much
and adjust it to your head shape but the
most important part of headphones is how
they sound and as an open-back pair of
headphones of course these sound much
better than closed back headphones for
the same price you can see right through
these headphones here showcasing that
open design and you know headphones like
the beats by dre and the v-moda cross
they LPS closed back they create a seal
they're noise cancelling or isolating
open-back headphones have a much bigger
soundstage which means you can hear the
cymbals behind you the trumpet to your
right the saxophone to your left and he
can snap to the beat just like you're in
the room with the musicians recording so
this does really really well with vocals
with jazz with orchestral music and all
sorts of stuff like that you might not
have the best sound for synths because
those are natural sounds and it's hard
to sound like you're in a room next to a
synth but everything really else natural
sounds super lifelike and very rich in
the SRA D eyes now with all these pros
comes one major downside and that is
again that they're open back headphones
but that means they're going to sound
like portable speakers to the person
next to you they leak a lot let's have a
listen
you
overall though I love the SR ad is for
the price and the category there is just
no contest they are durable and their
feature pack and they just sound
flat-out awesome the design is a point
of contention for some people and even a
buying point for others come but it all
comes down to how they sound really and
they are worth every single penny of the
99 dollars that you pay for them highly
highly recommended I've been asked to
compare these to some higher-end
headphones and I will attempt that but
these are absolutely perfect for someone
who doesn't necessarily consider
themselves an audiophile yet
you